all right joining us now here on the
show is one of my favorite people that
have gotten to meet in his 10 seasons in
the NFL third round pick out of I
believe SMU yes indeed and the 2010
draft my gosh this is unbelievable how
long he's been at this now with the New
Orleans Saints I love this signing
Emmanuel Sanders how are you sir I'm do
describe me your shelter in place what
is life like for you Emmanuel and a wife
and I'm gonna block there for three
weeks so it's like a roller coaster
rides like cleaning up all day behind
the kid telling them don't do that don't
do this and watching Netflix with my
wife and hanging out cooking and that's
really chilling my son has a respiratory
problem so I really I took all
precautions okay even before they told
us to go into quarantine like I took my
son out of school like a week prior so
it's been a it's been a long process but
you know hopefully everything comes down
here soon and things can get back to
normal I'll friend no doubt about how
old are your kids
Emmanuel how old are they I got a three
I got a three year old and a six year
old my son is the oldest of my daughter
history Wow
so are you will imagine like this is
probably the most of I think everybody
could speak for this opposed I've been
at home and the most probably cleaned up
and wash dishes more than this oh yeah
like I've been trash more than system
more than I've ever done you know oh yes
you did hello me cleaning up behind him
we're all folded laundry we're all doing
that as best we can and again thanking
everybody in the health care industry
and hospitals for being on the front
lines of everything so yeah we're
staying at home as you see all those
photographs of nurses holding up the
signs and doctors you know we're here
for you you stay home for us as you are
doing Emmanuel Sanders but are you
watching tiger King are you doing that
on Netflix it yesterday and I hear what
you guys are talking about is it
definitely a crazy show it's very highly
dramatic Beth Rio was entertaining I
enjoyed watching it you know my wife's
not so much because she thought it was a
show and everything but I enjoy
there's the fact that these people are
really going into cages with these
Tigers and how they treat the Tigers and
how they look at it as a business and
everything for me there's no way and a
heck you can give me an extension with a
whole bunch of Tigers I'm not doing it I
love my life I'll see you I'll see it
outside outside the gates I don't need
to go inside the fence so I could feel
dangerous I played football for a living
yeah the route is called a bang eight
for a reason right because you're the
one getting the bang right right
somebody's getting the bang maybe yeah
and probably I don't think your contract
there's probably a clause in your new
Saints contract or somewhere that says
that you can't do what Joe exotic was
doing pretty much I'd imagine right I
guess so Emanuel Sanders here on the
Rich Eisen show let's get into it what
was your free agent process like with
everything that was going on obviously
you said you haven't moved in three
weeks and it's been a unique times walk
me through what the Emanuel Sanders free
agency tour was looked like and wound up
being you know March I think when they
said March 20th or some or no 18th right
and for some reason creates you really
started March 16th I don't I don't I
don't get why they even say it started
in New Year's this day because people
were signing already prior to free
agency I guess that's the day you could
sign but riddance
that whole grace period that's where you
know the phones are definitely ringing
but you know I didn't know where I
wanted to go and you know I spoke with
the bills for a little bit and you know
I told him like let me think about the
idea and give me a night and like thirty
minutes later the stephane big deal went
through it I was like okay so then I
kind of waited you know I was talking to
Green Bay I was talking to
I was talking to the Niners they just
try to figure out you know what type of
deal what's that money area talk about
it and then other things called
you know how this I was ecstatic about
them cause an opportunity to play with
Drew Brees and everything you know the
numbers made sense and you know Drew has
two more years left on its do and I
sided two year deal you know I guess I'm
just excited to be in the war on this
thing you know I looked at the schedule
we got 11 or 12 you know games inside in
a dome and you know Michael Thomas being
my counterpart rebreathe throwing a ball
Sean Payton calls the plays you know
wide open spread often is just like I
was we paid in 2014 like you know it
just just set a new fire under me you
know this is not 11th season for me to
be excited how I am and why eleventh
season as if it's like my first season
you know it it's everything that you
want you want something to give you that
burn the fire to go out grind hard just
so you know when the season comes what's
at stake and what that city is looking
for and at the Super Bowl or Bush and
obviously you being paired up not just
with Drew Brees but can't guard Mike
that kid Michael Thomas is one of the
most special receivers this game has
ever seen and I and I know he's only
been off the campus at the Ohio State
for just a couple of years but he is
pretty damn special have you been in
contact with him or how do you see you
meshing with this young man that's
caught everything including a record
that Marvin Harrison had up until last
January definitely takes pressure off oh
my god bees also take pressure off for
him and work together and that's
definite our office you know I'm I
haven't you know reached out to Mike or
he has a reached out to be really
communicated but eventually gotta happen
but you know one thing about me is I'm
not gonna force anything I'm just gonna
let it happen actually it's kind of like
when I left distilleries in cane the
Broncos on 14 the various times at the
top of this game as well you know going
to Pro Bowls and all froze and it's the
same thing you know I just
and I just be me most most guys respect
me for just being beating so you know
I'm looking forward to getting into that
locker room they mentioned with the guys
having fun with the guys but also
working our butts off because you know
at the end of the day you know we the
reason why I joined a New Orleans Saints
because you have a great opportunity you
got a great team to do something special
what I say special it's to get to the
Super Bowl and try to win it all get to
the pinnacle of this game the highs of
this game and so I understand that you
know like I said I'm not gonna force it
but I'm just gonna go in and work my
butt off and see where the chips fall
what was your conversation with Sean
Payton like was that one like text me
yeah he texted me and he told me to go
and look at the film with what they've
been doing the past 12 years I think he
said oh and and he was like you love it
here and I didn't even go look at the
film by texting him back that's in ten
seconds and I said and look I don't have
to go and look at film I said I know
what you guys have done I know that
system produces you know I've been
fortunate enough to play with Julian
Jones at SMU in a spread offense a wide
over the past office and I'm sort of
crazy numbers and well it was fortunate
enough to play with the page and 14-foot
crazy numbers up and so I'm a fan of
past happy offenses I'm a fan of
offenses that spread the ball around and
spread out a defense and chunky you know
left and right left and right that's
like a receivers dream and so I've
always been studying John and drew and
how they go about their business when
Lance Ward's to all the great receivers
there's been that system it's almost as
I'm just excited to be in that system
and I'm looking forward to seeing what I
can do off the next time I'm I don't
know what I can do but so you know but
I'm excited about it you can figure it
out I mean and I imagine you've
connected with Brees so far yeah yeah
I haven't even signed yet because I got
to get the physical with the OCO
mid-nineteen thing I have anyway had my
physical but right when you know drew
found out that I have picked the same
thing we have worked out to be
text me tonight just text me and now I
haven't had that since 14 when pay
attention he takes me he was the first
person to text me for my family could he
be texting just talking about how
excited he is the work I always say is
the work for me and I texted back and
said I'm excited to work with him
looking for doing some special but you
know it just goes to show you know if
you're young quarterback out there and
this we true leadership starts at the
quarterback position and you know I've
been fortunate to play and play with
three Hall of Fame quarterbacks and just
just drew and paid me and we want to
talk about leadership those guys
understand it they understand that and
in order for a team to be good it starts
with the quarterback position and
getting guys I want to play for you and
I want to respect you and ready to work
so you know I that definitely made me
more excited to play for the Saints and
knowing that I got a quarterback like
that and then last one for you on this
in particular here Emmanuel Sanders
obviously there's more to it than just
you know who you're playing with or
catching passes from there's there's
contract length money etc so on and so
forth about family where you want to
live but did you technically choose
Brees over and Rodgers is that what you
told me just as well Green Bay
cold-weather Green Bay I can't do it I
ready to go to the woods I'm from the
South you know my grandma is six hours
awake and come to all the games Mike
have my family dried bugs it was just
perfect opportunity for me but I tell
you what it felt good and free agency
knowing that you know team shoe or on
the verge of trying to win a Super Bowl
we're trying to bring me in and you know
I never I never take things like that
like that lightly because I know it me
so it definitely made me feel gain but
at the end of the day okay so whether
and your grandmother essentially were
the Saints aces in the hole in landing
you
and the financials okay that helps
finance me yes you had a finances alone
area they wanted me to sign a three-year
deal and I wouldn't I didn't want to
sign a three-year deal so okay Emmanuel
Sanders here in the Rich Eisen show all
right I'm gonna put you in the role of
paparazzi if you don't mind put you in
the role of analyst that you have done
so well for us at NFL Network for a
couple of post seasons one in which you
were hurt and it was so great to watch
you come back from that Achilles injury
at your age which again is something
that I'm sure you don't want to talk
about but it is significant as a wide
receiver over the age of 30 for you to
do what you did was incredible that said
all put together the conversation
throughout much of late February and
early March was that Tom Brady would be
a great fit in San Francisco and the
49ers might actually want to twitch in
that direction because of a lack of
belief in Garoppolo and what fed that
was the fact that there was so much
running going on to get San Francisco to
the Super Bowl in which there was a
certain wide open wide receiver towards
the end of that game that got airmailed
by Jimmy Garoppolo is there any there
there is there any smoke any fire in
that part of the conversation about
Garoppolo with the 49ers Emmanuel
Sanders in being in that locker room of
being a part of that organization you
want to talk about a guy who was the
ultimate leader a guy who might have
this mistakes but Richie you see this
guy he'll throw three interceptions you
go talk to him and he'll just be like oh
well like I just got to keep fiery and I
got to keep firing he doesn't budge and
I've seen many quarterbacks when they
when they I've never seen Jimmy go
anything
I've seen many quarterbacks they go to
interceptions and they going to tank I'm
just like oh snap let me go and talk
this guy never had to have that moment
with Jimmy I just think right now like
with Jimmy it's it's you know coming and
being a backup with Tom Brady and
leaving a patient organization they
coming over to San Fran I'm over that
this guy down in San Fran eterna the
organization of rap they weren't winning
games and then he gets into the lineup
been traded it went six games in
ro and then he tears his ACL and it's
really his first season starting as a
quarterback really its first season
starting a full season as a quarterback
and takes the team to the Super Bowl and
and for me I just don't think it's fair
you know because you see a lot of guys
in there under scrutiny but you just got
to give Jimmy turn you know give him
time give him opportunity I just think
that right now everybody's pressing the
gate pret you know they're pressing the
gas on them to try to speed up the
process but your kid is speed up time
time is going to show you know what your
guys about and and if you're going look
at his win percentage and look at his
win record as a starter it's like 18
percent or so and so I remember um it
was a couple games that I looked over at
Gibeon was like this guy is a winner you
know this guy is a winner you check his
checkers record you check his percentage
he's a winner you know at the end of the
next you know our running game was our
running game we were able to run the
ball wherever to win games but that's
not to go to say that it was because of
Jimmy Garoppolo as he could why changing
why trying to prove a point that oh I
quarter back and throw the ball and we
should run the ball at 300 yards on the
team and win by 30 or 40 points and so
you know plenty of games with Jimmy that
we had to rely on in orem you go back to
the north same game we were down 21
points and Jimmy came in and we came
back and we were slinging the ball all
over and he converted you know the deep
ball to me and the third is I think
seven uh George killer when it was just
making throws we won games and we won
games off Jimmy arms of you want games
off off to run games and so I just think
that you know we Thomas got to get Jimmy
time but what I see right now is just
your greatness based off his win
percentage and his character in the way
this guy comes to work every day well
that is definitely a full-throated
support of Jimmy G right there walked me
through that play in the Super Bowl I
was referring to that balls in the air
you thinking this is a touchdown I'm
gonna have the game been a legendary
place for me a gimme but you know I
believe in destiny I just it just went
our time you know after like it was the
cheese kinda kudos to them but then I
remember I cop all the play over
coming out and I see the corner he blow
I'm just like oh my slide past dude I'm
like just get up on his toes you're not
rushing and I hear Jimmy's and I go and
I beat the corner and then I look and I
see the shaking you know I started
running I see the balls in the air and
I'm like oh this isn't right there is
probably about two or three steps after
I saw the ball in there I was like only
smell like he it's too far is too far
you know I ended up trying to get it and
the guy tripped me up in the fall and
clapping my hands cuz I do that was
opportunity for us to capitalize you
know win the game but I didn't I didn't
think the game will be over based up
that play because we had another played
right it just wasn't our time you know
and you know Jimmy Jimmy knows it and I
know you know that was the opportunity
of a lifetime for us to capitalize on
but it didn't happen and so we move
along you know I don't I don't have no
any resentment you know I don't say old
Jimmy's a bad quarterback cause of one
play you know it just didn't go our way
so you know it is what it is okay and
yeah I mean what was he like in the
huddle right after that just moving on
just to to I guess put a after the game
I had so empowered by the hotel he just
walked it to me and he's just like many
a night and I was like Jimmy look I was
like doing the whole world is gonna try
to beat you up over this fast and I told
him I said brother I love you I said I
love you remember I was like you know at
the end of the day just one player many
players that we've made we've made that
play over and over practice it is what
it is just wasn't destined for us to be
so you know and give me one of the
reason one of those times you're not
gonna beat yourselves well you know you
don't look at it just like me because
you know if you stood up and you beat
yourself up over something that you
can't control it anymore you're the only
harming yourself and so he's one of
those guys you're gonna be able to put
into the rearview mirror and move on and
look forward to the next opportunity
yeah I mean I was going to finish up our
conversation with our question of the
day which is you know Apple has come up
with the technology to allow somebody to
take back a text if they sent it in the
wrong way or the wrong person and what
would be the sports moment that you
would take back
if you could hit unsend or take back is
that the one from your old life career
or is there another one Emanuel I think
so that's we have play if I can get that
back and connect on a perfect path and
right into the end zone you know that
that's the legendary moment you know
rich you know what that means you know
that means that for receiver for
coolyback that's that's that's the play
that they're running over and over all
NFL is you know is that collection you
know it unless you know passing holes we
went down with you I think like what 47
seconds left or so right over our
minutes unless the scored if we would
win a game connecting on that pass
that's the legendary moment so
definitely that moment you know but it
wasn't make a beat alright Emmanuel are
you aware you went to the you know
obviously where they first fix free fax
but you went to the Super Bowl with the
Steelers I think in your first year
second year right second year correct
first year right then you went to the
Super Bowl with the Broncos won Super
Bowl 50 then you went to the Super Bowl
with the 49ers do you know how is the
who is the only person in NFL history to
go to the Super Bowl with four different
teams are you aware of where that would
be no so you are aware you are aware
that you have an opportunity that nobody
so good luck to you on that I hope sure
hope that I get a chance to see
everything that in this crazy-ass world
clears up a well enough to see you on
that field with the fleur-de-lis
catching passes from Drew Brees Europe
you're an a-plus person Emmanuel I love
chatting with you and I appreciate the
time best to your family
appreciate you right back right back at
you follow them and at East Sanders
underscore ten on Twitter I do you
should as well and add Emmanuel Sanders
with two M's on Instagram right here on
the Rich Eisen show